voilà ce qu'on sait l'adjudant-chef
kelly est le troisième membre avoir été
attaqué
[Musique]
les trois tireurs sont morts
sa femme a été également tués
ils n'ont plus qu'à espérer qu'il ne
survive pas
pourquoi ces deux longs à l'homme le
plus dangereux et le plus efficace qu on
est sur le terrain
[Musique]
ils m'ont tout pris
c'était des attaques étrangères sur
notre territoire les deux vont réagir
je vais régler cette histoire
[Musique]
il ya une partie de moi
ce que rien apaisera
une partie de moi que rien ni personne
n'arrêtera
aucun remords
ça ne vous a pas effleuré que john kelly
et puis faire quelque chose dont on est
pas capable
il faut avoir une certaine ouverture
d'esprit pour analyser certaines
situations
[Musique]
demain non pas censé avoir survécu
salut jek je peux avoir une grande
bouteille de bijoux tu sais quoi de ger
valence mode de grandes bouteilles oui
parce que demain est incertain
affirmatif mon pote
je me plaignais d'avoir à subir tous les
jours la même chose maintenant chaque
matin c'est pareil sérieusement
chaussures opale en
tulle embrouille tout le basket
hockey quelqu'un veut un café j'ai pas
comment c'est possible
je continue à revivre la même journée
désolé mon grand
chaque fois que je vois ce qui est
arrivé à mon appartement
je peux pas m'empêcher de penser
je n'arriverai jamais à récupérer ma
caution
sap a toujours été comme ça il y avait
une femme que je n'ai été magnifique
par fils que j'aime
maintenant une bande de connards ne bute
encore et encore
je meurs jour après jour
si jamais la capacité de réécrire
l'histoire était bien réel et si nous
pouvions efacec mon erreur
prototype nous donne le pouvoir de dieu
grand rien mon fils je vais revenir pour
toi
comment je peux arrêter tous à txema il
ne s'agit pas de l'arrêter mais plutôt
de le relancer c'est exact une fois
passée la stupeur je veux que ça
s'arrête
[Musique]
ils ont une armée entière
moi tout ce que j'ai c'est le temps
je dois apprendre à combattre à l'épée
j'en connais un qui n'a pas chômé
[Musique]
j'attends ce moment depuis très
longtemps
faire ça toute la journée
[Musique]
notre père qui est aux cieux que ton nom
soit sanctifié que ton règne vienne que
ta volonté soit faite
[Musique]
amis
père daniel garcia je vous présente le
père peter costello le bien daniel est
fortement recommandée c'est notre
nouvelle et meilleure recrue
qu'est-ce que l'archevêque de la
compétition mais vous êtes le meilleur
exorciste ceux qui ne t'a pas si c'est
qu'ils peuvent enseigner les prières
mais ça ce n'est pas ce qui nous
différencie des prêtres ordinaire il
faut que tout soit prêt à assumer des
risques
change de vêtements l'ensemble à un
prêtre
un exorciste ne se cache jamais du mal
ils se ruent sur lui tu sais ce que j'ai
vu
l'incarnation du mal
ce petit a besoin d'être celui ça aux
infos ce matin
berson a tué sa famille
qu'est ce que tu attends alors
je vous connais
père daniel
je vous ai vu en rêve
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ou deux
le dumont et m le plus puissant que j'ai
jamais eu
le diable est malin
il a besoin d'une armée
et une armée a besoin de soldats
[Musique]
pour pouvoir se multiplient devenir de
plus en plus puissantes
parce que j'ai un compte à régler
[Applaudissements]
non non
[Musique]
on
peut faire des choses avec sa tête et
avec son ventre avec la tête on peut
faire des maths ou avoir des discussions
compliquées avec ses parents
nous allons prendre un nouveau départ
alors
est ce que vous en dites vous aimez
je vais bien arrangé non
[Musique]
tu viens d'où j'ai demandé quelque chose
reste la honte a dit la loi est-ce que
tu faillite arrête tout de suite tu
t'excuses joy d'asile
[Musique]
est ce que tu veux battre nous avons un
coût non je frappe et je veux me
défouler
je m'entraîne je veux devenir kick
boxeur
accueillis
c'est tout ce que tu as pu enfin ces
salles kick boxer ça allait revient aux
hommes
il se passe beaucoup de choses dans ta
tête
t'es pas tout seul tu sais on a tous nos
soucis
là je ne vois pas un tigre je vous en
achète chiale pas je peux pas supporter
je sais que tu as me ressaisir et que je
dois réussir
je le sais j'en ai conscience
c'est pour ça que je viens ici
[Musique]
ça doit sortir du ventre
ma mère fait comme si tout allait bien
mon thème pense qu'à une seule chose
c'est lui
[Musique]
y'a aucun moyen qu'on te sortent de
cette situation sans que tu passes par
la case prison
j'ai un plat rond
[Musique]
les clippers qui est à nouveau je le
revends disparaît on ne verra plus
jamais d'enfant ou
on peut laisser un bébé dans un hôpital
sans qu'on lui pose des questions c'est
la loi c'est toute seule je refuse de la
lui rendre c'est clair
est-ce que tu as une idée du temps tu
passes en prison pour un an et demi je
n'ai pas enlevé arrêter tout ça lui
je voudrais voir dans mon bureau
toi tu resteras loin de fléchir et tout
ça je te le promets
je qu'elle soit en bonne santé et qu'il
soit 11
tu sais elle me sourit
[Musique]
mais merde
d'un ballon à devenir
et je laime aussi je sais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore bonne mine toute réussite ni
intérêt
ne t'inquiètes en changera de nom
est montré qu'elle dure important il est
né avec une malformation cardiaque j'ai
besoin de quelqu'un pour l'aider à vivre
d'autre chose juste charge quelqu'un on
ne cherche pas j'ai trouvé
pas du tout un concert ou coup
franchement je trouve que la vache mans
les enfants par un handicapé moi je
trouve que tu as l'air bien crever pour
un mec en pleine forme
on n'est pas contre tous les avantages
que vous avez vous les handicapés que
j'ai envie de pisser aurait fais pas le
con je frapperai passait bien
super 15 heures bouche de boisset dormoy
du matin
c'est quoi votre expérience avec les
sens
j'en étais un coup je le suis toujours
ça fait 25 ans d'expérience
mais on m'a dit que vous aimez écrire
tout ce que je voulais ans comme un noël
sans jamais jusqu'à sur la liste pas de
bonbons pas de gâteau à cause de son
diabète parce qu'en plus il fait durer
oui pas de sport tout effort physique
quoi tout le reste
t'as jamais embrassé une fille à ton âge
et il était temps j'arrive dans ta vie
mon patin
c'est quoi le programme aujourd'hui
excursions champêtre et un sms avec
photos toutes les craintes
elle va jamais croire et tu me prends
pour qui va
initiation à la botanique en forêt
c'est pas moi qu'ils mardyck et un
médecin kimouche aussi mal et c'est
peut-être pour ça qui te fait confiance
alors
[Applaudissements]
je dors à avoir une vie normale
hu
[Musique]
3 2 1 partez
allez allez allez année continue fonce
si tu finis dans les dix premières qui
rejoindra l'équipe cet automne
la coupe du monde les jeux olympiques tu
pourras faire ce que tu veux
[Musique]
douze ans c'est trop jeune mousse et
entraînements on n'aurait pas dû
accepter
tu vas prendre de vraies vacances
silva dont
moi c'est un des bons jours
mais attention c'est un cadre en carbone
un cadre en carbone
[Musique]
tu as besoin de te reposer mais je dois
m'entraîner quand tu as le choix on
peint de ta santé salut je m'appelle
viti madison chock dee de venir au bal
parc dégâts
t'auras pas besoin de ça il suffit que
tu es confiance et que tu te laisses
aller
y arrive
[Musique]
c'était un peu trop propre
on va camper au sommet alors ça doit
grimper vous n'avez pas beaucoup pas du
tout bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je cherche un coéquipier pour une course
des preuves à vélo je vais le faire avec
elle
si tu te fais mal tu te ra entraîné pour
rien tu as envie de retourner là-bas où
c'est seulement pour faire plaisir à
tout faire
aucune chance de gagner contre tous ces
adultes le plus important c'est d'être
présent pour ses amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
c'était de la folie
[Musique]
vingt-huit mois
un dieu son match de sa contrée
fischer
[Musique]
m
né de marque de futurs répéter
[Musique]
il faut
autre
[Musique]
ce
marché
[Musique]
cette
salle
[Musique]
d'audience
une enquête ces animaux là
[Musique]
m non
vous êtes tués
[Musique]